je suis végétarien pas de chance une
tare des gens marginaux voilà comment
était décrit les végétariens dans les
années 60 en france certains
journalistes tentaient tout de même de
goûter aux plats sans viande non sans
une certaine appréhension
nous avions ce soir dans un endroit
unique au monde mais en tout cas en
france
c'est un restaurant en libre service
uniquement végétarien vous êtes en train
je crois de manger une escale heures de
blé les blés et je trouve ça fort beau à
cette époque la majorité des reportages
sont réalisés de la même manière les
journalistes regardent de haut
c'est étrange personne qui se privent de
viande pourtant le discours des
végétariens des années 70 était
prophétique
d'un point de vue écologique des fines
sauf les lâcher on est végétarien pour
des raisons socio économiques nourrir du
bétail coûte cher et c'est gaspiller une
part trop importante de l'alimentation
végétale au détriment des hommes des
arguments qui se vérifie aujourd'hui un
chiffre par exemple
selon les nations unies l'élevage
contribue à 14,5 pour cent des émissions
totales des gaz à effet de serre mais
les années passent et les végétariens
sont toujours regardé de travers
exemple avec cette diététicienne
quelques peu virulente
moi je suis absolument d'accord avec les
gens qui refusent la société de
consommation et le progrès mais à une
condition ce qui marche pieds nus et qui
vivent à dos d'âne dans le désert
saharien
entre les années soixante dix et 2000
la consommation de viande des français
explose et les végétariens eux tentent
tout de même d'aller contre les idées
reçues bien tenace la cuisine
végétarienne a la réputation d'être une
cuisine un petit peu triste ce que anor
veut combattre cette fausse idée c'est
méchant préjugés nous on veut faire une
cuisine gay avec beaucoup de couleurs et
puis surtout très copieux en 1998 les
français mangent et en moyenne 94 kg de
viande par an et par personne
c'est un record
mais les idées végétarienne progresse de
façon masquée pour ne pas heurter de mon
végétarienne aime pas être employé quand
je sais pas pourquoi c'est lié pour
certaines personnes à une forme de
sectes ne sait trop quoi
alors que c'est pas du tout ça malgré
les préjugés le nombre de végétariens a
augmenté 10 % des français
envisageraient même de se mettre au
régime sans viande et sans poisson est
aujourd'hui le steak de céréales n'a
plus rien d'exotique comme dans les
années 60 mais il est servi à la cantine
de l'école
[Musique]